I think that's how to choose openings he
does open with the King's Pawn so we are
likely to see the Sicilian Defense
French defense Magnus did use this
yesterday to beat Anish giri yeah well I
don't think we could expect either of
those moves really I mean E4 uh from
hands is a bit of a surprise and E6 even
though Magnus did play it's a surprise
and what variation will hands now play a
number of moves to player David from
from that white could play right I
suspect he's gonna pick up his Knight
and uh defend the pawn in the center I
mean the trendy line is the advance now
there's been some sort of new ideas and
the advanced variation where uh White
often gives up a pawn and he has though
played played your move your Vancouver
the tarash variation
so yeah maybe White's safest kind of
most secure choice in that position just
even if black plays very accurately here
it tends to lead to equalish positions
so Han's not going for the advanced
variation pushing white Central pawns
forward gaining space which uh kind of
yeah would lead to more double-edged
scenarios okay Magnus challenging the
center still well known stuff White
Snake come out uh comes out I had this
position myself in the Olympiad uh from
the white side but okay my opponent
didn't choose this move
trading off a set of Pawns in the center
Anish giri in his chatsworld course does
recommend bringing Black's Queen side
Knight out now to challenge White's
Knight in the center of the wood
I mean up until yesterday's game against
Anish giri you know Magnus really
doesn't tend to play this opening with
the black pieces but he is following
anisha's recommendation and there's
going to be some trades
I'm still within uh very well known
territory here Black's dark squared
Bishop coming out I think that's what
Anish giri recommends in his course so
there's two great friends Magnus
preparing hard there were two very
theoretically important games in the
Olympia just a couple of weeks ago in
this position where black pushed his
King's Pawn forward one square just to
block the center occupy as many Central
squares as possible so is Magnus go
going to go for the most critical move
which has featured recently in some high
level games or is he gonna just try and
confuse hands with maybe a less
well-known move I mean do you make
mistakes but uh David
different level and Magnus developing
his Knight and I have to say this has
been such a thrilling start to day two
of the FTX crypto Cup on the Oslo
Esports Arena I mean it was just
incredible yeah you know just to see the
emotion he gets up close and personal
and uh meanwhile okay the action is
still continuing because players are
simply developing their pieces but at
the same time the skeleton has been
built you know white is definitely
marked out their intentions it's going
to be happening on the right side of the
board and Magnus is going to be relying
on his Supremacy there in the center
explain very provocative chess allowing
white to establish this kind of Central
Pawn on E5 and okay he's trying to gain
a bit more space here this is still
relatively uh kind of well known at
least the ideas I'm not sure about the
exact move order which I think is a bit
rare he's going to position where he can
attack at some point he's playing one of
your moves there and he's got a position
where magnus's King is always going to
be a little bit fragile so uh still
obviously early days but personally I
think I think I'd go for white in this
position at the moment if he withstands
whites initiative and I love long-term
prospects so I'm gonna go black you
mentioned the long-term prospects I
guess it all lies on this Pawn short
term it's a great attacking weapon it
controls so many squares but uh Magnus
if he can somehow
um trade off these Bishops if you can
somehow trade off these Queens then long
term this Pawn is actually a Target this
point is a weakness the white has
overstretched
um so it looks slightly
counter-intuitive Magnus has now castled
it looks like the encounter intuitive to
kind of be left with these weak isolated
pawns on the queen side but Magnus does
have these great two Bishops and his
second most popular quote last one I
mention is you know sometimes I amaze
myself
that sounds like that could be after
that first game something you would say
so yeah I'm not sure whether he's
Blended or sacrificed a pawn uh in the
current position and we've just seen
Magnus eliminate the White Knight I have
oh I'm slightly afraid for Huns now
because uh the position is simplifying
which doesn't favor him we mentioned
Hans wants complex positions but uh
let's just restart uh kind of retrace
our steps here just two moves ago he
played his Bishop to this Square
blocking the Queen's defense of this
pawn and uh after the Queen's defense
was taken away the elimination of this
Knight does mean that okay we want to
capture with the queen we don't want to
wreck the white Pawn structure in front
of our King ideally uh so if we take
with the queen now suddenly this key
Pawn that we've highlighted that we've
talked about it does drop and okay we
will see this happen like this
immediately eliminates this pawn and not
only has black one upon he does have an
attack on this Square I think Hans his
idea was to take this black pawn back
wow yeah I just don't see what Hans has
in mind and the fact that he's paused to
think okay this is the current position
the fact that Hans Paul there means that
he is unsure as well he's a bit nervous
about what is to come most likely just
steps to the side yeah okay he didn't go
for this I guess the problem here for
Magnus is there is a pin on this uh on
this diagonal the black Bishop is uh
slightly vulnerable instead Magnus went
for maybe the safe approach uh not the
most ambitious he moved his Queen to the
square so same idea just different order
um so attacking this pawn and attacking
the white Bishops and uh Hans therefore
needs to trade off as many pieces as
possible so we arrive in this position
level pawns level pieces but uh Black's
Bishop is the dominant of the two and uh
now attacked on this one yeah the attack
on the spawn as well definitely I
thought uh Han's move was quite good
actually because it was more or less
forced and kind of controls every single
Pawn but Magnus here captures the pawn
anyway it's definitely White playing for
the draw now yeah I would keep the
Bishops on the board and the Han says
yes he would too it's interesting
because I would uh I think I wouldn't
hesitate here I would take the Bishops
off as long as the Queens are on the
board I would be terrified of allowing
the Bishops to stay because uh with
opposite color Bishops it's easier to
attack the enemy King White's King here
has only three pawns shelter Black's
King has four Pawns see I think it'd be
more impressive if Hans draws this game
than actually winning the last one yeah
um against Magnus because he's a safe
Pawn down
um this kind of position the Magnus
thrives in uh to save I think his
chances of course but he needs to swap
off all the Rooks really uh in order to
save this game
well the right time may be stepping up
his King and maybe lining up the bishop
and queen along the same diagonal uh I
think there's still a lot of play left
in the position and I have to say it's
terrible weather here like it is awful
yeah I mean he has thunderstorms
lightning okay Queen fans the bishop
it's been pretty horrendous in England
yeah just a Relentless sun and which
might sound lovely but you know
England's not really prepared for that
and never gingers either
yeah not not good for me yeah so yeah
and I heard that situation and we have
some moves on the board obviously just
interrupt us David but it was extremely
hot in Chennai as well correct it was
the first tournament in years that I've
worn a jacket at the wood normally I
take the jacket off it's just a shirt
during a game but I had to put the
jacket on
um they were struggling with the climate
it's got a toughen up wimps
or women needs to start controlling the
temperature in chess tournament Arena us
maybe yeah definitely Kaya
okay and meanwhile there's been a set of
Trades actually a pair of Rooks have
left the board and uh oh I think this
increases the chances for hands to
secure that very important draw but on
the other hand you know when I do
compare the Bishops I mean White's
Bishop not great just uh biting on a
brick wall you know a Black's Bishop is
just awesome
yeah and uh you guys know I did release
this chessable course with Magnuson
grinding
um kind of out these small advantages
and this is the perfect scenario to
grind as black for zero risk you're a
pawn up worse comes the worst you trade
off the queens and Rooks and it's just a
draw with opposite color Bishops but you
can just kind of tease your opponent for
the next 50 moves you just slowly kind
of step forward the black kings maybe
push a pawn here or there just try to
occupy some open files with your pieces
and white can't really force all the
exchanges David every time soon so this
is like uh yeah it's a dream scenario to
kind of press with no risk I could not
give you the satisfaction of just just
slowly killing me here you know I'd be
like yeah cheers David yeah
I don't accept your resignation
there used to be a rule where you can
refuse resignation oh there used to be
that I think that was some weird raw I
don't know but maybe just still seems
very good for black but the Rooks come
off that it will be a draw in the middle
game you're gaining space and in the
ending is a good move so and that's
actually quite interesting actually if
you're ever able to play G5 you're doing
well as black which I thought was just
weird but good move though I think yeah
yes black has great winning chances but
um at least it's less to worry about for
white but the fact that black was able
to achieve this move means that long
term this Pawn is also a weakness it can
never find a safe Square where it's
protected by another white pawn and for
example if it ever steps up uh in this
scenario it will just become isolated
these are two weaknesses now so black
has two weaknesses to Target this is why
this uh Pawn push is such an important
one and if you compare that to White uh
here what can white Target there's
nothing white can ever go for and I'm
slightly surprised Magnus is pushing
forward so quickly but he has clamped
down so these two pawns are now fixed
and they won't be able to move for at
least a while so if you're trying to win
opposite color Bishop uh ending or we
see some exchanges here probably is that
you uh want to put your Pawn pawns on
the same kind of square as your
opponent's bishop and if you're trying
to draw the position you want to put
your pawns on the opposite color Square
to your opponent's Bishop looks like
White's totally tied down right yeah
and now you can see Magnus is really
massaging his advantage through you know
he's pushed forward with more pawns the
black king is going to step forward and
there's just no move
that her hands can do apart from just
wait with the bishop if you really want
to cut across your opponent's plans then
you can just step this Pawn forward and
it's it's exactly what Simon said
actually here the pawns control the
light squares the bishop controls the
dark squares and that's why it's such a
good strategy just kind of get active
with the with the work and I'm just
thinking you know maybe grab the G4 Pawn
but okay he instead he goes for the wait
and see approach it's very difficult to
do that just to sit there and wait for
the ax to fall uh slowly but surely
start pushing forward okay he is going
for the strategy maybe even black can
start going
um towards this side of the board with
his King
okay he is on this journey
might as well just resign if you're
doing this yeah
you like to resign early Simon it does
seem that way it really does yeah what's
the point of suffering in a hopeless uh
situation yeah I mean against Magnus I
resigned anyway I think here against
David I reside well it seems to be all
about the black pieces uh here today so
far in the first round two games ended
up with winners and they both had the
black pieces in game two Series going on
right now well the bar seems to be all
the way over to the black players side
jancrest of Duda looking good for him
against LeBron aronian and alireza
verusia the bar all the way over to his
side in game two going up for the world
champion and it's that type of advantage
that will keep growing that Magnus has
an other top top Grand Masters they show
that we can learn from you know he's
going for a particular setup this
particular kind of ending and he knew
exactly what he wanted when he went for
that exchange I just find that really
you know good to learn from basically
those kind of ideas
um for future non-stop for I mean Magnus
has been playing these end games for 20
plus years but that's how he kind of his
uh judgment is so uh so kind of in tune
with the position because he knows
exactly what he wants in the end game
yeah and uh that affects his nutritions
in the opening of middle game rather
than uh specific moves
and yeah hands reduced to waiting still
the hammer will fall eventually at some
point either Black's King will go over
towards that lonely white Apon or okay
he's gonna get ready to push one of the
Pawns in the center of the board
try to kind of do a golden run and win
two pawns at once that looks like it
would be very very strong Magnus he
won't want to take any risk though I was
going to say he will pause and calculate
a little bit but uh no he just goes for
this immediately
and how is white Gonna Save that cheap
one now
can the white king step to the right he
has to otherwise he would have gone two
pawns down but now there's going to be a
discovered check yeah and the king is
steps back and suddenly that Bishop
doesn't have a safe place to go has to
go on the edge of the board it's not
going to find any Solas there I think
the king can attack it again
that's right really nice way to finish
right yeah exactly wherever the bishop
goes the black Rook will move it's a
discover check and the bishop Falls
maybe you just have to use the white
Rook to defend it now and
your fingers but uh that that one I
think is losing either way
this one
fortunately chess speaks for itself and
there's I mean it's setting up a really
exciting next two games between these
two yeah yeah very interesting one point
and we didn't see any tie breaks
yesterday
we have to see some today that would be
very strange yeah we've seen
surprisingly few this season I know we
keep expecting them but the players
they're so aggressive so direct Magnus
has won a second pawn and there we go
Hans resigns oh what a comeback it was
by Hans Neiman in the first game but
world champion Magnus Carlsen he makes a
comeback of himself